we have someone here we want you to meet
yeah all you to do is just Clooney
Trumper in your gold or do yourself
please aye Clooney charm you the day we
met what do you did I gave you
gravity Clooney with a little bit of
three kings mixed in you never even saw
it coming
I'm not in social media at all someday I
want to be able to tell my children that
their mother and I were at the same
place at the same time that I had got up
the courage to say hi I'm Jed Tasha it's
really sweet but if I mean a guy have to
be able to Google him like a deep [ __ ] I
want to know his likes and his I mean
don't you mean dislikes hey Dad I love
that picture of you with Usher yeah that
was a fun night
when was that listen you're obviously a
gifted artist I want to help you help me
with what I'm interested to see if I can
take someone like you and grow their
falling to a significant place Ted you
are gonna be the guy every girl wants to
be with Frankie dawning under Jed I have
not seen you since high school actually
that's not true where she's got your
life looking so incredible I mean I'm
your closest friend and you were not
that exciting oh my god
if he's here relax there's no way to see
my picture the pictures been like over
million times [ __ ] right from Vegas cool
you remember when we would spend maximum
an hour a week in front of a computer I
used to have to write things down on
paper whoa
four million followers who's us just a
regular guy good work Tosh why did you
start lying about yourself I just didn't
think the real me was enough I'm not
gonna get that yeah you are gonna get
that this is the universe reaching out
to you in the form of uh sure you don't
screen uh sure's phone calls
[Music]
it's a miracle
[Applause]
where are you going I don't know let's
find out
[Music]
you